let's divide seven thousand one hundred
and eighty-two by forty-two and what's
different here is we're now dividing by
a two digit number not a one-digit
number but the same idea holds so we say
hey how many times does 42 go into seven
well it doesn't really go into seven at
all so let's add one more place value
how many times does 42 go into 71 well
it goes into 71 one time and we're
really just a reminder we're just doing
the process where we say hey 42 goes
into 71 one time but we're really saying
42 goes into 70 100 100 times because
we're putting this one in the hundreds
place but let's put that on the side for
a little bit and focus on the process so
1 times 42 is 42
and now we
subtract
now you might be able to do 71 minus 42
in your head knowing hey 72 minus 42
would be 30 so 71 minus 42 would be 29
but we could also do it by regrouping to
regroup you want to subtract a 2 from a
1 well that's not so you can't really do
that in any traditional way so let's
take a 10 from the 70 so that becomes a
60 and give that 10 to the ones place
and then that becomes an 11.
and so 11 minus 2 is 9 and 6 minus 4 is
2. so you get 29 and we can bring down
the next place value bring down an 8.
and now this is where the art happens
when we're dividing by a multi-digit
number right over here we have to
estimate how many times does 42 go into
298 and sometimes it might involve a
little bit of trial and error so you
really just kind of have to eyeball it
if you make a mistake try again the way
you know you make a mistake is if you
say it goes into it 9 times and you do 9
times 42 and you get a number larger
than 298 then you overestimate it if you
say it goes into it three times you do
three times 42 you get some number here
when you subtract you get something
larger than 42 then you also made a
mistake and you have to adjust upwards
let's see if we can eyeball it so this
is roughly 40.
this is roughly 300
40 goes into 300 the same times is 4
goes into 30. so it's going to be
roughly 7
roughly 7. let's see if that's right
7 times 2
is 14
7 times 1 is 28 plus 1 is 29 so it got
pretty
pretty close my remainder here notice
294 is less than 298 so i'm cool there
and my remainder is less than 42 so i'm
cool as well so now let's add another
place value
let's bring
let's bring this 2 down and here we're
just asking ourselves how many times
does 42 go into 42 well 42 goes into 42
exactly
one time 1 times 42 is 42 and we have no
remainder so this one luckily divided
exactly 42 goes into 7182 exactly
171 times